a simple game you don't have to be an
emotional intelligence genius are you
happy more times when you wake up than
you are not attention is the number one
asset until you love yourself and really
have self-acceptance along with
self-awareness you will not have nice
days you will have anxiety you will have
down days you will struggle here's
what's so up and amazing about
this you get to decide you have to get
out of blame To Love Yourself you
blaming your parents for is
allowing you to have a package a
container to continue to not love
yourself we must become more emotionally
accountable we are capable to get free
meditation you are capable to get free
exercise AKA like push-ups in your room
walking on a hill you are free to
recognize that you're hanging around
people that are negative and you can
start limiting that time and you can go
to the person that's most positive in
your office and be like hey Carly I want
to be your friend can I take you out for
lunch you are in control until you love
yourself nothing will happen you're
allowed to love yourself cuz you're the
judge and the jury